news air travel in the u.s hit its  highest level since mid-march  raising concerns about another surge in  covet 19 cases  about 1.1 million people passed through  security checkpoints on saturday that's  according to the tsa  december was the most deadly and  infectious month of the pandemic  the u.s is averaging more than 2 600  deaths per  day dr anthony fauci projects the  pandemic will only get worse here in the  next couple of weeks because of the  holidays  while there was an increase in travel  during the holidays numbers are still  down from last year  airlines are not expected to get  significant relief until the  second half of this year u.s airlines  losses likely topped 35 billion dollars  in 2020.  the pandemic ended a decade of profits  in which the industry hired thousands of  workers  bought new planes and expanded networks  it's been a really tough few months for  them